now to the border crisis a new report
revealing the united states will start
transferring some migrant families into
ice custody as border facilities deal
with overcrowding some of them operating
at nearly 600 percent above capacity
here to talk about it is former acting
ice director ron vitiello tell us in
your mind so what happens the migrants
then get transferred into ice custody
what happens next
thanks for having me on it depends on
what situation that they're in if
they're if they're young children
without their families they'll have a
brief stay with border patrol and then
on to hhs custody into a shelter
eventually replace placed into the
united states uh families uh with the
with older children can be expelled
currently under title 42 back into
mexico and then families with young
children are being released in record
numbers and you've seen the images your
audience has seen the images you know
here we are the most powerful country in
the world uh here in 2021 and we can't
develop policies to keep the surge of
humanity coming to our borders every day
so
the border patrol is totally overwhelmed
you heard about the capacity numbers i
feel bad for my former colleagues in the
border patrol because they know
solutions for this problem exists we do
not have the political will at the
administration or in congress to fix
this problem therefore those individual
border patrol agents and now isis
assistants uh they're left to pick up
the pieces and and they're terrible
conditions well take a look at this also
chris cabrera who's the border patrol
union vice president was talking on fox
news on saturday
about this issue that many of the
migrants could be coped positive but
they don't have good numbers here's take
a look at this
not everyone we encounter we test only
those exhibiting some type of symptoms
and not everybody has symptoms that has
it and and we're releasing people out
the door uh day in day out with uh with
actual uh positive tests for kovit and
and more just keep popping up so you
have that situation plus so here are
some pictures we have of migrants being
smuggled in
in carpet in plastic bins
it's 102 degrees outside there are
people in there ron
it shows you the disregard that
smugglers have for individuals as
they're transporting them uh the
conditions down there inside that
vehicle 102 degrees during a pandemic
face-to-face um and then chris he's a
front-line agent uh he's part of the
union leadership i consider him a friend
of mine so he knows clearly well what
the solutions to this problem is he
knows what the contours are he knows
that the job of a border patrol agent is
very risky but on top of the risks that
they face each and every day to protect
us on that border they now have to deal
with covid and the people in the
pipeline are not practicing social
distancing they're in overcrowded stash
houses they're in tractor trailer rigs
they're in over packed vehicles and so
chris knows that that problem exists and
the and the risks that his the agents
and their families face
ron there's now bipartisan calls for
president biden to put a new border czar
in charge and not vice president kamala
harris take a look at senator graham
she doesn't know what she's doing
i don't dislike her but she's suggesting
that we should
invest a lot of money in the northern
triangle countries
but not change our border policies
congressman cuellar's district is under
siege and the hospitals are having a
competition for bed space between
illegal immigrants and american citizens
and henry's district is being overrun
there's coveted positives everywhere if
we don't get new eyes on this problem
the worst is yet to come
ron your thoughts on that
there's clearly no interest at the white
house level including with the vice
president to fix this problem and so
lindsey graham is as a former chairman
of the judiciary committee henry cuellar
not only a legislator over homeland in
the house but also a board of residents
somebody who's represented laredo for
many many years and he's done it very
well even as a democrat i agree with his
policy which is let's stop this chaos
let's fix the problem let's put some
resources in place so it doesn't so it
isn't as bad as it could be and then
congress also could act here right they
could move toward getting the
administration to go back to the migrant
protection protocols to to re-engage
with the northern triangle on the asylum
protocols but clearly at the white house
level they're not ready to do that yet
and so there has to be another there has
to be something else done and the
legislature could act uh to force this
moving forward when you look at the
conditions of what the people are
dealing with plus your own border patrol
agents
and what's happening all across the
country it's hard to imagine
how more you have what you need to do in
order to get washington to pay attention
and decide to act
it's really remarkable to me including
on the politics of it ron um that's my
musings for this morning thank you for
your expertise we appreciate